remember why are we looking at this
left-hand side what are we going after
we don't actually need the whole thing I
only need a particular part of it okay
so remembering that I mean all of these
remembering that this times this really
means you take this guy and multiply by
all of them if you take this one and
multiply it by all of them and so on
there are very very particular ones of
those pairings that are going to give
you constant terms okay so I want to
call out a parent that you can see right
this is what I mean by bless you
making the logic clear right that guy
and that guy when they come together the
exes will all cancel leaving you with a
constant term but it's not the only one
it's not the only one this guy will also
pay with this guy and give you a
constant term right and you can keep
going oh this is why I wrote the second
last term even though I always never do
that the second last term here
pairs with the second term here and then
lastly all the way upwards at the end
you get these guys pairing up so tell me
how many pairs on it how many pairs I
believe there are n plus 1 pairs there's
a pair of these for every single term I
think every single term matches up ok so
now I'm going to write sorry I don't
even need to sign there I'm gonna write
those pairs just the pair's because
they're the only ones that give me
constant terms so they're the only ones
I care about okay
so therefore therefore the left-hand
side constant time is equal to now be
careful let's go to the middle and I
started with the first one here the last
one there okay I'm gonna get a binomial
coefficient here and then I have another
binomial coefficient there and then what
happens is X's again they cancel which
is the whole point this is the left-hand
side constant time okay so there's my
first pair I've got my second pair which
is this pair of guys right now even
though I didn't write the third last
term
see what it's going to be right just to
establish your panel you'll be NC 2 + NC
+ - 2 + dot a dot and then you finished
out the sequence by cutting back to
these guys so you're gonna end with an N
+ 0 you see it's this blue and that blue
ok so I won't underline all of them but
you can see that came from that rib
hibbott see that okay it's really
meaningful
this line is crucial this nice crucial
aha but-but-but-but by but you're like
oh that's not what I wanted oh oh this
is what I wanted but those are the same
because of why because of the symmetry
identity and I should write that because
I'm trying to prove this thing right NCI
is equal to MC n - R right so if for
example I put 0 in here I've got 0 there
and then I've got mm mission and hero
and sister and NC n are the same thing
so I've got that guy and I've got that
guy and I've got all the rest of them
all the way up to NC okay well a lot of
times there but now I get to finally say
equating constant terms and I should say
constant terms rather than just
coefficients because you might be
equating the x squared terms or the
executors or who knows what you're going
to be equating so to demonstrate
understanding that you know what you're
doing totally which attends your
equating that's a really good idea
Ukraine the constant terms and now all
that's left is just to write down the
result you're trying to prove right and
z0 that Square and that Square and that
square all the way up into the end by
some weird crazy Pascal's triangle like
magic will give you go twice as many
rows down go to the middle term and
that's exactly what all those squares
are not - which is crazy okay
that was a lot of work that was really
hard this is what makes it harder
identity now will point out to you part
of what makes this time is because
you've never seen any of these before so
so many of these steps like what why
okay so I'm going to ask you to have a
go at hot and being of the thirst for
questions in this exercise because
you'll practice these two skills picking
a substitution sometimes just to be nice
to you they even tell you what
substitution to use secondly which is
much trickier compare in coefficients
right which coefficients are going to
give me the ones that they seem to be
particularly after okay so first of all
questions husk a and B that means you'll
skip a whole bunch of parts we'll come
back to those when I show you this is
method one substitution method suit
comparing coefficients is a third and
final method which I will show you later
okay